push-ups fantastic for building strength
endurance explosive power core strength
and a perfect counterbalance to the high
rep push-up is the body weight row which
is an anti flexion movement missing from
many of our diets and it's fantastic for
scapular control the lit to handstand
press this is a hybrid
movement fantastic pressing power core
strength compressive strength cross body
clean and press one exercise that trains
so much rotation a hinge a squat a
press and the CAC squat a rare movement
in the frontal plane fantastic for hip
mobility the med ball slam essentially a
reverse vertical jump rotational throw
brilliant for building that rotational
power and finally The roope
Climb